The time is coming either you prepare
to rule or you pray for her mercy
i am to at the iron throne
she will block my way she will never bend the knee
Welcome back everyone it's charlie they released
a house of the dragon episode 6 and beyond trailer
already so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel i'm doing videos for all the
episodes just like i did for game of thrones be
sure to subscribe to get them all we're also doing
a giveaway for hbo max subscriptions all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and post all
your theories on what's happening in the footage
down in the comments below we'll just start at
the beginning of the trailer and talk about the
footage shot by shot going through it starts
with a new scene of daemon and caraxes flying
to dragonstone then we have a scene in the yard
of the red keep like this gated area here that
you see a couple times on the show and this is
an older version of aegon ii practicing his sword
fighting with what seems like his brother eamonn
targaryen also known as a man one eye later in the
trailer he's this character here that everybody's
confusing for matt smith with the eye patch this
isn't matt smith this is meant to be a completely
different actor playing an older version of eamonn
one eye he hasn't been born yet on the show that's
because all this footage is coming from like
a much bigger time jump at the beginning of
episode six and through the rest of the season it
seems like what's happening here is they're just
practicing their sword fighting and kristen cole
or someone else is training them here you could
tell that it's them because they're wearing the
green colors underneath their practice armor for
the greens like the other side and the dance of
the dragons even though when you think of green
and game of thrones you think of the tyrells like
the tyrells wore a lot of greens there's green in
their banner i believe this is from episode five
where alicent comes to rhaenyra's wedding to
laenor velaryon wearing the green gown and that's
like the beginning of her wearing the color green
all the time and the different sides in the dance
of the dragons which happens much later in the
timeline like the actual conflict happens much
later in the timeline but the different sides
are referred to as the blacks and the greens and
the names are references to the colors of dresses
that the two are known for wearing in these next
couple of episodes like we'll just see why it
is that they wear those colors more often the
other funny detail here too is you know this is
practice because alicent considers aegon ii to be
the true heir even though he's much younger here
like he hasn't taken the iron throne or anything
like that at this point if he were actually flying
into battle on his dragon it all them get dragons
like there are a lot of kids obviously that are
being born there's all these questions about
whether or not rhaenyra is pregnant right now
later in this trailer like the trailer that we're
talking about right now you actually see her first
two sons shakira's and lucerus much older with
the older version of emma de arcy playing rhaenyra
i think she's still supposed to be in her 20s at
this point i believe episode 5 is the last episode
that we'll see this season with the younger
versions of the actresses and rhaenyra is still
in her early 20s when this is happening it
seems like her sons are still very young so
not like that much time has gone by like less than
a decade so that's why you have aegon ii being so
much older here but not like really old and if he
were actually flying into battle he'd be wearing
much more ornate armor suitable for a king kind
of like daemon's very expensive looking dragon
scale designed armor this is just another shot of
one of the targaryen design ships they actually
explain the differences in some of the ships
that they use around westeros so for example the
ship that you see rhaenyra on especially in the
previous episodes like the targaryen design ship
is more like a light cruiser like a pleasure
yacht that the crown just uses for fairing
the targaryens around this part of the realm and
back and forth between dragonstone and blackwater
bay like it's more of a short-range pleasure yacht
type of ship as opposed to cordless valerian ships
which are like heavy cruisers that he uses for a
lot of his trade that are much more heavily armed
way more men on them designed for travel across
the narrow sea like much more dangerous waters
then there's a shot of otto hightower telling the
younger alicent this might still be from episode
five as he departs the red key because he's
been fired recently by viserys that she needs
to prepare aegon the second to rule or pray for
rhaenyra's mercy like he's trying to strike the
fear of the gods into her and he's saying that if
she doesn't do anything that rhaenyra is going to
become queen and reiterates that the king is also
going to die i know there's a lot of questions
about what's going on with viserys what is he
dying from like what is the actual problem here
it is otto hightower or someone else complicit
in it like is somebody trying to speed his death
because there were all those scenes of him being
cut by the iron throne that is a big piece of the
lore from the books the whole idea that the realm
believes in this rumor that the iron throne will
kill anyone who's not meant to sit on it and
that's why the people who sit on it who aren't
meant to get cut technically that's a lie because
pretty much everybody that sits on it gets cut at
some point during the events of game of thrones
cersei for example gets cut by it all the time
even robert baratheon got cut by the iron throne a
couple times it is the most stabby looking throne
that you've ever seen it'd actually be hard to
sit on it and not get cut by it even if you were
paying attention to something like that the actor
who plays viserys patty considine actually did an
interview where he explained the truth about
what's actually happening to the stairs like
why his health is declining so quickly and you get
a better shot of him much later in the timeline in
the trailer here where he looks way worse and he's
wearing that golden mask to hide part of his face
because his ailment has started to affect part of
his face basically and this might look familiar
some of you may have figured this out based on
this particular shot paddy considine and this
is canon like he explained this it's meant to
be cannon to the show is supposed to be dying
slowly from leprosy that's what's affecting him
and during the events of the trailer here like
wherever this shot is happening whichever
episode he's gotten so bad that it started
to affect his face his eyes and he's just wearing
this mask around because he started to look so bad
i know there's going to be all kinds of theories
about the maesters having something to do giving
him leprosy it's not particularly contagious so
even if he touches his children the queen other
members of court he wouldn't necessarily give
it to them so it's not like he's passing around
leprosy around the court here now i think what's
actually going on in his head is he's trying to
maneuver like he's got this grand plan for putting
aegon the second on the throne and that's what
he's thinking about so he's kind of underhanded in
that aspect but he's not actively trying to make
the king die faster there's a brand new scene of
vhagar flying over a crowd of people all massive
still waiting to see which episode she actually
shows up in supposedly there was a deleted scene
from a previous episode where her new dragon
rider claims her and she is a female dragon
no spoilers for that like i've talked about it
in previous episodes they've heavily foreshadowed
who the next person to write vhagar is going to be
we'll see them again in episode five so hopefully
there'll be some more references to them writing
vhagar please don't spoil that in the comments if
you know but there's a reason why they kept
mentioning vhagar several times in previous
episodes vhagar is just meant to be the biggest
oldest dragon at this point in the timeline
and the whole thing is the older the dragons
get the bigger they get we'll meet rhaenys
current dragon meleys in episode five that'll
be like the next brand new dragon that we see
possibly vhagar soon after that this castle in
the background could be a version of heron hall
the turrets look kind of run down and melted which
would be classic harrenhal but the scale doesn't
seem quite right like harrenhal is supposed to
be massive like huge we saw it at the beginning
of episode one in the flashback to the great
council of 101ac like this is meant to be
harrenhal that's how big it is this is the older
version of renera played by emma darcy several
years goes by like i said between episode five and
episode six i believe she's still in her twenties
their scenes of the older otto hightower looks the
same basically like even though he's meant to be
several years older he looks pretty much the exact
same he did in previous episodes it's the younger
actors that physically changed the most obviously
but he's talking to the older alicent now played
by olivia cooke spending most of her days wearing
green ever since the wedding banquet in episode 5.
this is corlys velaryon's throne room inside his
castle in driftmark the castle is called high tide
and it's filled with all these treasures and items
from all of his voyages across the world we'll see
that again during episode 5. there's the voiceover
from older rhaenyra saying she's going to inherit
the iron throne and at this point it sounds like
viserys's health has declined so much that the
topic of the succession has become a big thing
like they're all thinking that it could happen
at any moment as they focus on a shot of viserys's
crown which is jaehaerys's crown also on the show
we're probably gonna see aegon the conkers crown
2 which is like a completely separate crown
i'm not sure that viserys's crown is made of
valyrian still it might be but i know that
aegon the conker's crown which is much smaller
looking is actually made of valyrian steel then
there's another scene in the same gate of the
red keep of the yard here where harwin strong
starts a fight with kristen called neither one of
them are wearing their armor so somebody may have
insulted someone else like kristen cole may have
insulted harwin strong this scene of the horse is
actually daemon grabbing rhea royce's horse as it
bucks up at runestone in the veil that's actually
from episode five as far as i know this is what
ria royce actually looks like the funny thing is
that daemon was talking to rhaenyra about her
calling her the bronze as if she was this very
unattractive person that he wanted nothing to do
with but she actually looks pretty good looking
like she's actually pretty hot i think that's just
meant to get across the idea that daemon's kind of
a dirt bag like i think the joke is that she's
actually fairly pleasant she's very good looking
just like a totally normal person that anybody
would be happy to be married to except for daemon
then there's a scene of someone in what seems like
a fire happening in this castle whichever one this
is happening in in the bed chamber the footage is
a little too blurry to see who it actually is it
just seems like there's a fire in the background
out the window here then there's a scene of older
vernier and older daemon on dragonstone talking
about the dance of the dragons in alicent she's
saying she's going to block her way so it's more
of the actual dance beginning like still part of
the prelude her kind of formulating her actual
plan this scene is of daemon entering the iron
throne room in what seems like the wedding from
episode five like he's wearing the same outfit
that he has on during the wedding banquet in
episode five and it just seems like all the
other members of court here are shocked and he's
kind of swaggering in like oh yeah you thought i
got banished but i'm totally back again then
this battle footage actually seems like it's
old battle footage from cordless valerian's men
attacking crap feeders army the triarchy at the
stepstones back in episode three not a new battle
and this last scene of older alice in hightower
is her sitting in the small council room meeting
with her version of the small council which is
called the green council rhaenyra has her own one
called the black council for the blacks like the
other side in the dance during the actual dance
of the dragons rhaenyra is also referred to by
the realm as the black queen that's one of her
nicknames so it's the blacks versus the greens
the black council versus the green council the
black queen versus aegon ii alicent isn't trying
to put herself on the iron throne she's trying to
put her son aegon ii so technically when you're
talking about heirs battling with each other
it's actually aegon the second versus ronira but
really is alicent fighting on aegon ii's behalf
but if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
trailer footage that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments like
i said some of this might be from beyond episode
six it could be like episode seven episode eight
my full episode five video will post sunday after
they release it and then they'll probably release
like another dedicated episode 6 trailer with
footage just from episode 6. so i'll do a new
video for that too when they release it make sure
you enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
any of that stuff everyone click here for my new
house the dragon deleted scenes video from the
first half of the season there's a whole bunch
of deleted scenes and everyone click here for my
full house the dragon episode videos i'll update
the link with episode 5 as soon as i post that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!